und jetzt das heute journal
in allen einen guten Mittwochabend der
45 Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten ist
wieder dort wo er am liebsten ist im
Rampenlicht der Öffentlichkeit egal ob
man ihn katastrophal findet oder verehrt
oder einfach nur Ruhe will an Donald
Trump ist schwer vorbeizukommen wieder
einmal aber einiges ist diesmal neu noch
nie zuvor musste sich ein US-Präsident
in einem Strafprozess verantworten ein
mega Promi mit Secret Service
Leibwächtern als Bürger auf der
Anklagebank das Volk von New York gegen
Donald J Trump steht über den Vorwürfen
der Staatsanwaltschaft Trump sieht das
anders für ihn soll der Prozess
Rückenwind bringen bei seinem neuen
Anlauf Richtung weißes Haus Claudia
Bates
er badet in ihrer Verehrung nach einem
schwierigen Tag in New York nutzt Donald
Trump die Bühne vor geladenen Getreuen
in seinem Anwesenden Florida um den
Ereignissen seinen eigenen Stempel
aufzudrücken trotz klarer Warnung des
Richters beschimpft er diesen und den
Staatsanwalt der Staatsanwalt ist hier
der Verbrecher ich habe einen Trump
Hasser als Richter mit einer Trump
passenden Frau und Familie
der gescheiterte Staatsanwalt das ist
Verfolgung keine Ermittlung
universiation hier dagegen war Trump
machtlos die Tür fällt einfach zu hier
ist ihm niemand zu Diensten im Gericht
in New York ist eher nicht Herr das
Geschehens was ihm sichtlich Unbehagen
bereitet Trump soll systematisch
schweigegeldzahlungen orchestriert haben
die ihm den Weg zur Präsidentschaft 2016
Ebenen sollten schädliche Informationen
habe er vor den Wählern verheimlichen
wollen in 34 Fällen seien Unterlagen
gefälscht worden um solche kriminelles
Verhalten zu verbergen
im Staat New York sind das Straftaten
egal wer du bist wir können und werden
strafbares Verhalten nicht normalisieren
der Angeklagte Donald Trump plädierte
auf nicht schuldig bei seinen Anhängern
wird ihm die Anklage nützen 90 Prozent
meinen es handele sich um politische
Verfolgung die Republikaner versammeln
sich wieder um ihren Ex-Präsidenten und
der macht sich das zu Nutze will Kasse
machen mit einem falschen Polizeifoto
das T-Shirt 36 Dollar Spenden sammelt er
auch seit der Anklage bereits 10
Millionen Dollar
nach Deutschland wer krank ist und auf
ein Medikament angewiesen sollte nicht
anfangen müssen danach verzweifelt zu
suchen aber genau das ist immer wieder
die Situation in einem der reichsten
Länder der Welt zuletzt auch bei
lebenswichtigen Krebsmitteln zum
Beispiel oder bei Antibiotika
Deutschland kämpft mit Engpässen bei
Arzneimitteln ein neues Gesetz soll das
Problem nach Ansicht von Regierung und
zuständige Minister jetzt in den Griff
bekommen wie das funktioniert und warum
es Zweifel gibt ob es hilft dazu Britta
Spiekermann
sebastian tude ist Apotheker in
Flensburg es kommt immer häufiger vor
dass er sagen muss haben wir gerade
nicht lieferingpässe jetzt sieht es so
aus dass wir einen großen
Lieferengpass bezüglich Penicilline für
Kinder haben und auch Erwachsene was
hier in Schleswig-Holstein besonders
ärgerlich ist weil wir eine riesen
scharlachwelle haben und die Kleinen
nicht versorgen können es hört nicht auf
mit der medikamentenkrise Minister
Lauterbach kommt jetzt der
Pharmaindustrie entgegen bei Kinderarzt
Malmitteln aber auch bei einigen
Krebsmedikamenten für Erwachsene sollen
die Hersteller die Preise um 50% anheben
dürfen damit wird es auch den Schlaf
für die Arzneimittelfirmen interessanter
arzneimittel für Kinder in Deutschland
zu liefern oder gar zu produzieren das
ist an diesem Tag nicht die einzige
Baustelle Stichwort Pflege die Beiträge
steigen zum ersten Juli für Kinderlose
stärker als für Eltern Größe Familien
sollen sogar entlastet werden viel kommt
allerdings nicht an auf der pflegeseite
5% mehr Pflegegeld 5% mehr für ambulante
Pflegedienste auch die stationäre Pflege
soll stärker bezuschusst werden für
jeden ein bisschen die Branche empört
insgesamt ist das weiße Salbe auf einen
grundlegend marodesystem wir brauchen
eine grundlegende Reform dieser
Pflegeversicherung
Lauterbach glaubt dass seine
Pflegereform hält zumindest für diese
Legislatur und bei den Arzneimitteln da
glaubt der Minister dass die Engpässe
bald Geschichte sind
eine symbolische Geste heute in Warschau
der ukrainische Präsident ist zu einem
offiziellen Staatsbesuch gekommen roter
Teppich olivgrüne militärhose Polen ist
für volumenski mehr als ein Nachbar die
Regierung in Warschau hatte immer wieder
westliche Militärhilfe für die Ukraine
angemahnt und so Druck auf andere
insbesondere Richtung Deutschland
gemacht vielen Dankbarkeit heute also
für die Unterstützung aber es gibt auch
Probleme zu besprechen zwischen Polen
und der Ukraine aus Warschau jetzt
Natalie Steger
der ukrainische Präsident impulk er
mischt sich demonstrativ und das Volk
trotz der Sicherheitsvorkehrungen dieser
Besuch ist für viele in Polen längst
überfällig angesichts ihrer
Unterstützung Dankbarkeit will selensky
vermitteln an diesem Tag auch im
Warschauer Stadtschloss
Russland wird gegen Europa nicht
gewinnen solange Polen und die Ukraine
Schulter an Schulter stehen
damit punktet selenski gilt doch
Russland als ewige Bedrohung Polens für
selenski Warschau stets ein Vorreiter
für seine Forderungen anders als ein
zögerlicher Westen laut duda hat Polen
bereits acht seiner Kampfjets Typ Mick
29 ins Nachbarland überstellt sechs
weitere sollen folgen
wir geben anderen Ländern ein Beispiel
manchmal überwinden wir sogar ihre
Sturheit und Widerstand was
Waffenlieferungen angeht
Polen der Helfer auch in Sachen
Flüchtlinge allerdings treten bei
steigender Inflation im Land
Ermüdungserscheinungen auf außerdem
erzürnt polnische Bauern das
ukrainisches Getreide die heimischen
Marktpreise verdirbt wir haben einen
Ausweg gefunden in den kommenden Tagen
und Wochen werden alle Fragen geklärt
sein
besiegelt der Verkauf von 100 radpanzern
aus polnischer Produktion an die Ukraine
für Polen bedeutet die Situation im
Nachbarland auf lange Sicht auch
Geschäfte machen
und dann ein Auftritt heute in Moskau
der russische Präsident empfängt die
neuerkreditierten Botschafter der EU und
der USA dazu hast du mehr Gundula ja
dabei hat russlands Präsident Putin
erneut den USA die Schuld am Ukraine
Konflikt gegeben die US Außenpolitik
habe zur heutigen Ukraine Krise geführt
sagte Putin bei der Akkreditierung von
insgesamt 17 neuen Botschaftern im Kreml
auch der EU machte Putin schwere
Vorwürfe die Europäische Union habe eine
geopolitische Konfrontation mit Russland
eingeleitet
die NATO kündigte unterdessen an die
Ukraine noch intensiver mit einem neuen
strategischen Programm zu unterstützen
und ihr damit den Weg zur geplanten
Mitgliedschaft zu ebnen mit jährlich 500
Millionen Euro sollen bis 2033 auch
institutionelle Reformen begleitet
werden zudem berieten die Außenminister
der NATO über das Verhältnis zu China
Nato-Generalsekretär Stoltenberg warnte
erneut vor chinesischen
Waffenlieferungen an Russland
inmitten des muslimischen Fastenmonats
Ramadan ist es auf dem Tempelberg in
Jerusalem zu gewaltsamen Zusammenstößen
zwischen Palästinensern unter
israelischen Polizei gekommen
350 Menschen wurden festgenommen die
Polizei stürmte die Alexa Moschee
unruhestifte hätten sich dort mit
Feuerwerkskörpern verbarrikiert von
palästinensischer Seite wurde das
dementiert in der Folge kam es zu
gegenseitigen Raketenangriffen im Süden
Israels und in Gaza
die Wirtschaftsforschungsinstitute
rechnen mit einer weiterhin hohen
Inflation in Deutschland von sechs
Prozent zugleich korrigieren sie ihre
Annahme vom Herbst das eine Rezession
drohe sie erwarten nun für 2023 ein
Mini-Wachstum von 0,3% und für das
kommende Jahr 1,5%
fehlen noch die gewinnzahlen vom Lotto
am Mittwoch sie lauten ohne Gewähr
4615 29 51 47 Superzahl 5 weitere
Gewinnzahlen auf Lotto zdf.de und im
zdf-text und das Wetter bringt zu Ostern
mehr Wolken als Sonne aber es wird etwas
wärmer morgen ganz im westendichte
Wolkenfelder und etwas Regen sonst
zunächst oft sonnig später wolkig aber
trocken 8 bis 14 Grad in den nächsten
Tagen eher unbeständig mit Schauern aber
dafür immer milder am Ostersonntag 8 bis
16 Grad
und das war es von uns in der Kurzform
um 0:25 meldet sich Nazan gökte mir mit
unserem heute schon mal Update von uns
allen nähern sie ein angenehmen Abend
und viel Spaß beim Fußball tschüss bis
morgen
[Musik]